justo aquí tenemos la gráfica de igual a
de x y lo que quiere hacer es bueno
comprobar cuáles de estas opciones son
realmente verdaderas y seleccionarlas y
como siempre los invito a pausar el
vídeo y vean se pueden resolver esto por
su cuenta así que vamos a echar un
vistazo a esta primera opción ambos
tanto el límite cuando x tiende a 6 por
la derecha dgt x como el límite cuando
extiende a 6 por la izquierda deje de x
existen entonces primero vamos a pensar
en el límite deje de x por la derecha es
decir nos vamos a aproximar a 6 x
valores más grandes que 6 así que se
observó cuando x vale 979 está por aquí
cuando x vale 8 de 8 está por aquí
cuando x vale 777 está por aquí
observamos estamos entre menos 4 y menos
tres cuando x vale
6.5 de 6.5
por aquí se está aproximando más al
menos 3 cuando nos fijamos en gm de 6.1
estamos como por aquí cuando nos fijamos
en x igual a 6.0 1 que de 6.01 está como
por aquí es decir nos estamos acercando
y acercando y acercando al valor de
menos 3 eso quiere decir que el límite
cuando extiende a 6 por la derecha dgt x
este límite que tenemos aquí si existen
y de hecho este límite es igual a menos
3 ok entonces este si existe ahora vamos
a pensar qué es lo que pasa con el
límite cuando x tiende a 6 por la
izquierda deje de x y bueno recuerda que
solo lo estoy viendo de manera gráfica
esto es lo que esperan que hagamos en
este ejercicio por lo tanto vamos a
empezar en cualquier lado que te parece
si nos fijamos en cuánto vale que cuando
x es igual a tres cuando x es igual a 3
g3 toman este valor un poco arriba de 1
cuando x vale 4 es de 4 tomamos este
valor que es ligeramente abajo de 2
cuándo x toma el valor de 575 toma este
valor que es parecen 3 cuando x toma el
valor de 5.5 parece que tomamos este
valor que es ligeramente abajo de cinco
cuando x toma el valor de 5.75 observa
que tomamos este valor que es cercano a
9 y entre más nos acerquemos más grande
va a ser el valor que tomamos ángel esto
a medida que nos acerquemos más y más y
más a 6 por la izquierda por valores más
pequeños que 6 entonces podemos decir
que en este caso la función no está
acotada nos aproximamos a infinito ahora
bien técnicamente diríamos que este
límite no existe entonces voy a tachar
este porque no existe y por lo tanto no
puedo seleccionar esta opción porque
este límite no existe
algunas personas dirán que el límite
este que tenemos aquí se está
aproximando infinito pero técnicamente
el infinito no es un valor al cual
puedas decir que te estás aproximando en
la definición formal clásica de un
límite decimos que el límite no existe
bueno vayamos a la segunda opción dicen
el límite cuando x tiende a 6 dgt x
existe bueno la única forma en la que
exista el límite es si ambos límites
tanto el límite por la izquierda como el
límite por la derecha existen y además
se aproximan a lo mismo así que en este
caso nuestro límite cuando x tiende a 6
por la derecha existen pero el límite
cuando x tiende a 6 por la izquierda ni
siquiera existe así que esta opción en
definitiva no puede ser verdadera por lo
tanto también la voy a tachar así que
estas dos no son opciones correctas y
vamos a la tercera que está definida en
x igual a 6 bien pues si nos fijamos en
su gráfica me aparecen que no está
observa si nos fijamos en cuál es el
valor de g
cuando x es igual a 6 bueno por este
lado tenemos un círculo abierto por lo
tanto no estamos tomando ese valor no es
igual a menos 3 y por el otro lado
tenemos un asiento tabla porque por aquí
se va hasta infinito esto es lo que está
pasando en x igual a 6 por tanto que
tampoco está definida en x igual a 6 por
eso voy a cancelar esta opción así que
las 3 primeras no son correctas vamos a
ver esta que es continua en x igual a 6
bien puedes ver que por este lado su vez
a infinito y da un salto enorme y
después llegamos por acá y continuamos
así que con un poco de sentido común
podemos decir que esto es bastante
discontinuo ahora si lo quieren pensar
más formalmente para que algo sea
continuo el límite necesita existir y la
función tiene que estar definida en ese
valor y tiene que ser igual al límite y
observa ninguna de estas dos opciones
existen por lo tanto puedo concluir
sencillamente que g
no es continua en x igual a 6 así que lo
único que puedo seleccionar en esta
ocasión es ninguna de las anteriores
ninguna de las anteriores es mi opción
correcta bien vamos a hacer un ejercicio
más entonces lo primero que nos dicen es
que ambos tanto el límite cuando x
tienden en este caso a 3 por la derecha
deje de x como el límite cuando extiende
a 3 por la izquierda deje de x existen
así que vamos a hacer lo mismo primero
me voy a fijar en qué es lo que pasa
cuando nos acercamos a 3 x a la derecha
por valores más grandes que 3 entonces
observa esta gráfica
aquí tenemos esta pequeña discontinuidad
y vamos a fijarnos en qué es lo que pasa
cuando nos acercamos al valor de 3 por
valores más grandes que 3 entonces
cuando x vale 5 g de 5 están como por
aquí es un poquito más pequeño que menos
tres cuando x vale 4 g de 4 está por
aquí esto es un poquito más grande que
menos 3 cuando tomamos el val
de 3.5 g de 3.5 está como por aquí
parece que es menos 2.5 por ahí cuando
tomamos el valor en x de 3.1 observamos
que gm de 3.1 está como por aquí nos
vamos acercando al menos 2 y se observa
ser de 3.0 uno está más cerca que menos
2 por lo tanto podemos decir que este
límite el límite de gtx cuando x tiende
a 3 por la derecha existe y de hecho va
a ser igual a menos 2 muy bien así que
ya tenemos esta primera parte ahora
vamos a fijarnos en qué es lo que pasa
con la otra parte quiero aplicarme en el
límite me deje de x cuando x tiende a 3
por la izquierda pero por valores más
pequeños así que vamos a fijarnos un
poco si observas si x valer 1 entonces
que de 1 parece que es un poquito más
grande que menos 1 si x vale 272 ahora
está por acá toma el valor como del 0
5 más o menos gente de 2.5 me parece que
es muy cercano a 1 es un poquito arriba
de 1 g de 2.99 parece que es muy pero
muy muy cercano a 2 gente 2 puntos 99
9999 es muy muy muy cercano a todos
cuando le aplicamos la función por lo
tanto observamos que este límite también
existen así que este límite existe y de
hecho es igual a 2 por lo tanto ambos
tanto este límite como este otro límite
existen y por lo tanto esta es una
opción correcta muy bien bueno entonces
vayamos a la siguiente el límite de gtx
cuando x tiende a 3 existe ahora observa
estos dos son límites unilaterales el
límite cuando x tienta 3 por la derecha
y el límite cuando extiende 3 por la
izquierda aquí queremos el límite
completo el límite real
para que este límite existan ambos
límites tanto el de la derecha como el
de la izquierda deben existir y
necesitan aproximarse al mismo valor
ahora en esta primera opción
vimos que estos límites existen pero
observa que no se están aproximando al
mismo valor por la derecha nos estamos
aproximando a menos 2 y por la izquierda
nos estamos aproximando al valor de 2
así que este límite el límite cuando
extiende a 3 dgt x no existe no existe
bien ahora vayamos a lo siguiente me
dicen que está definida en x igual a 3
bueno si observamos en x igualdad 3
podemos ver que aquí tenemos este punto
sólido que nos marcan que si está
definida y de hecho que de 3 es igual a
menos 2 entonces ésta sí es una opción
correcta si estamos definidos en x igual
a 3
gm es continua en x 3 bueno para que sea
continua en x igual a 3 el límite dgt x
cuando x tiende a 3 debe existir además
la función debe estar definida en el que
se iguala 3 y el valor que toma la
función en x igual a 3 debe de ser igual
al límite me deje de x cuando x tiende a
3 estos dos valores tendrían que ser
iguales pero en este caso ni siquiera
existe el límite cuando x tiende a 3d
gdx así que esta función en definitiva
no puede ser continua por lo tanto voy a
tener esta opción
puedes verlo aquí tenemos una
discontinuidad y bueno tampoco voy a
seleccionar ninguna de las anteriores
porque ya hemos seleccionado algunas
opciones acá arriba